hello YouTube just knows in my friends
this is brinjal here welcome to the
fifth and the final episode of dirty
chess tricks again Sicilian in this
lecture I'm going to show you some of
the wonderful tricks against specific of
Sicilian and the win gambit the spaz
Nico's dissident arises after the more
of fo c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d 4c
captures d4 Knight captures d4 and here
black plays the move Knight to f6 so you
can see that Knight is attacking the e4
so when white defended with the move
Knight to c3 black has this move in the
sleeve that is e Phi so grabbing the
center and same time hitting the knight
the mainline goes as follows white plays
the move Knight to b5
so there is a threat of Knight to d6 so
blackberries with the moon d6 himself
now here white has a couple of good
choices such as Bishop to g5 here for
but the move I'm going to recommend
contains some of the nasty tricks and
that is night to d4 so you can already
see those Knights are looking at the
juicy c7 square so that means black is
sponsored sprit e much force black has
to play the move Knight captures d4
afterwards what is going to recapture
the night theta e puh now the correct
move over here is Knight is going back
to the BH square but I found many
specific or players simply play the move
Knight to e7 because they don't like a
piece to be on down low and the trick is
set right here White has this a very
cute and innocent move that is c3 and to
your surprise
it's create one of the knocks G tricks
which not many of your opponents are
going to spot it now to illustrate it I
want you to show the first week where if
black is on
by the night and play the move ethics
then straightaway
white is winning after the move yep
Quinn to a four so it's not only pinning
the spawn but now there are some nasty
discord is going on when this night is
new and this especially happens in quick
games where as soon as you opera and see
that you are planning to give a discover
check he straight away put the Queen or
let's say Bishop in between but this is
the last time he's going to put this
because after Knight captures d6 its
smother Smith
so Essex lose the game on the spot here
most of the sveshnikov player will
continue with the move Knight to g6 and
the planning of the black is very simple
black wants to play the move Bishop to
e7 castle on the King side and then
start attacking white on the Kings side
with the move f5
well it all looks good and rosy
except once again White has this very
sneaky move that is Queen to f4
so I designed for that discover check
and there are two is black and get out
of this I don't like the first one that
is scheme v7 the simple reason is the
King has been misplaced on e7 and not
only that one can immediately start
attacking black king side why the moon
h4 to illustrate how dangerous this
position is I like to show you one of my
very quickly in this line where here my
opponent stop edge fire by playing edge
fire himself and now I played a very
tricky move that is Bishop to d3 here he
responded with the move Bishop to d7 so
painting my knight and now I played the
move Bishop captures g3 he responded
with the move Bishop captures defy so
idea is very right that he wants to
exchange some pcs because his King is
misplaced
but after Queen captures beef I
after wrong thinking he finally press
the resign button and rightly so the
simple reason is black is a piece down
black cannot capture this bishop because
if F captures g6 then after Bishop to g5
the black queen does not belong to this
world so that's why King Eason looks
very dodgy the 99% of your opponent when
they reach this position will churn out
this move Bishop to d7 and thinking that
everything is fine except there is one
move which creates a nasty trick and
that is Queen to c4 now instead of Queen
to see for the Queen to b4 is a stronger
move but it leads to some complication
where why it needs to know lot of moves
so that's why I'm recommending you
should play the move Queen to c4 so
what's the idea my idea is to play the
move Knight to f7 and grabbing the
exchange the only decent defense over
here is to play the move to see it
counter attacking the White Queen and
now what is going to play the move Queen
to b4 so this time around Queen to b4 is
exceptionally strong because it's
attacking the two spots one is on e7
but the most important one is on d6
because it can create a folk of King
Andrew I have reached this position two
times in my game in the first game my
opponent is pointed over here with the
move a six so his idea is to when I
capture the d6 pawn with a knight he
will simply capture it with his Bishop
but after a simple recapture with the
Queen we reach to a position where white
is a clear pawn up but not only that but
it has a bishop pair and the most
important feature race black cannot
castle on the King side so it's just a
winning position within ten to fifteen
moves of the kale in the second game my
opponent responded here with the move
Bishop captures be fine
which will be the case of many of your
opponent because they can eliminate the
strong night which was heresy in the
black camp and after Bishop kept his
beef I check black can happily play the
move King to e7 which at least assure
that black is not losing any material
well at first sight it looks fine but
the news are even worst now before we
move on I like you to pause this video
and find out a continuation where white
is completely winning okay I hope you
find this continuation that is Bishop to
g5 check so the only moon left is f6 and
after Queen to g4 BAM haha
so why dis create a checkmate straight
with this move and the funny enough is
even though black has so many pieces on
the board black cannot defend this
threat except there is one move that is
28 which will lose the black way so this
are some of the wonderful tricks exist
in Sicilian reznikov edition now to
conclude this series and put cherry on
the cake I like to show you one of my
own Patrick which I occasionally used in
blitz games to knock out or an even play
for the draw against a very high rated
opponent the trick exists in the vague
Ambridge which arises after the Mordor
fo c5 and here I place the move before
so gambling the b4 pawn what I found out
online that many Sicilians players are
not prepared against the wing gambit the
frequent response goes like this
so here black capture the b4 pawn and
when white offer the second-born that is
a three-two later create a counter on
the a and B file like deny to capture
that pawn and instead of that goes for
the recommendation
that is defy here white has no choice
but white has to capture this deep bone
and black recapture with the green now
before I move on from here onwards I
like to show you one interesting trap
from the black perspective which is that
here
if white foolishly captured the b-pawn
which happens between two twenty two
hundred plus player like simply plain to
move Queen to e5 and grab him they're
just early in the opening so keeping in
mind of that trap black is always going
to churn out this moves and hoping that
what is take that before Polly well yes
what is going to do it but first of all
what will play this freaky move that is
my twelve three so stopping Queen to e5
and the but obvious law is to play the
move Bishop to g4 and creating the same
threat again well yep that's true but
this time around we can allow black to
execute his plan and White has a
wonderful new that is he kept us before
most of the black players will be very
delighted and they will happily take
this night when white recapture with the
Queen if black wants to stay in the game
then he has to exceed the Queen but who
was do it as soon as you can see that if
you can give this check and you can nab
rook you just straight away go for it
the big difference over here is Queen is
not sitting on d1 but this turn around
this is on f3 so this makes a huge
difference here white will continue with
the move Bishop to e2 blocking the check
and what most of the black player thinks
that okay I can grab a rock in the
corner and now I can attack the 2pcs and
if wife takes the b7 pawn I will take
the night and after white recaptures the
rook I can capture the B for pawn and
not only saving my night but I will be a
piece up well that's true but
if white takes the rook in the corner
problem is when black capture the knight
on b1 white has this boom boom so this
is nothing but a clear checkmate I have
reached this position two times in my
game both against 2000 plus rated player
and the first game my opponent is
pointed over here with the move e5 so he
spotted that I'm going for the checkmate
but now black goes down the line very
very quickly here I responded with the
MU castle on the Kings side my opponent
responded over here with the move Queen
captures b1 but this is just asking for
it now it's time to finish the game I
played the move Bishop to b5 check my
opponent responded over here with the
move King to d8 and now I played the
move d4 so idea is to capturing the e5
pawn and then place the rook on d15 so
my opponent stopped this with the move
Queen captures c2 but he completely
missed White's
winning blow and I hope you find it
please pause the video and find the
winning blow okay it starts with the
move Bishop to g5 check and after the
move 6 rope to c1 and queen is Hank to
the depths it's funny that I read this
position against an FM and here after
long thinking he responded with a very
accurate move that is e 6 in fact this
is the only move which can save black
from all the difficulties here white is
more than happy to accept the draw
because this is exactly the result they
want against a very higher opponent so
there will be a perpetual and there is
no escape kindly note that a black tries
to become greedy and go to the f6 square
then white is now completely winning
after the move
wind capture see it the usual line goes
like this so here black capture the
night creating another threat of
capturing the bishop so why it has to
castle on the Queen side and now you can
see the big drawback of this pieces both
the Knights cannot move and that means
both the route cannot involve in the
game the only piece black and move is
the Queen Queen captures c2 has been
played in this game it looks very
obvious that queen is coming back in the
game but it's a big big blunder I want
you to pause the video and find out what
can be the wrong with this move ok I
hope you find this move that is Queen to
da check the only good move is Knight to
e7 now we play the move Queen to d4
check then after King to g6 Bishop to d3
and once again we back the Queen so this
awesome of the wonderful tricks in the
wing gambit which you can definitely try
in the shorter version of the games well
thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
lecture bye